hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to soma now there's the
first game that I've recorded since my
hiatus ended and I'm actually really
excited that this is the first game that
I'm gonna play because when I started my
channel the first game I ever did a
let's play off was amnesia the Dark
Descent and this is the next official
game by the same company that made that
one so the fact that I'm returning to
this one is really really interesting to
me and I've been waiting for this game
for practically years now because
frictional games who is the developer of
this game are incredible and making
terrifying experiences they made the
penumbra games they made I am these are
the Dark Descent they had a hand in
making a machine for pigs but obviously
that was the other company did that
reality is that which when you stop
believing in it doesn't go away thanks
Phil dick I think you're bleeding oh
that's nothing it's just my brain can't
stop bleeding from the accident hey take
this know that that's for later for the
scan it's green Ashley I need to tell
you something Simon please don't make
this weird no no it's not like that
why now who's David which is their never
enough time okay hello this is bizarre
why is my brain bleeding I have a lot of
questions right off the bat
hello David muncher okay yeah that's me
my name is David Munchie we spoke
earlier the brain scan I remember are
you all right yeah yeah just a bad dream
are we still on for today yeah that's
why I'm calling
I wanted to remind you to drink the
tracer fluid I sent you image of the
damages don't worry I got it somewhere
okay okay see you soon okay cool
in typical amnesia fashion I'm waking up
out of a bed but at least I'm not in a
medieval castle again that's another
thing that I'm really excited about
because Summa offers so many more custom
stories they actually intentionally put
in what is this hook you did hook at it
on a big zombie boob lady mark and Diana
Miller have blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah this is probably something
important for later and I might need to
know about this but right now hello I
forgot that this is a harvester yeah
whatever I don't need to worry about the
tracer fluid just yet I got all my cool
[ __ ] that I need to sort through okay I
already got that I know hooks does that
thumping sound okay so things are off to
a bizarre start but obviously this is
just the tutorial area considering that
I'm just going to be learning to
interact with the environment
screw this [ __ ] screw this [ __ ] we're
all this and we have a goldfish uh-huh
I even sent an email to remind him
didn't I remind him about what I didn't
even know that I was working this
weekend I don't know what you're talking
about
okay nothing over here nothing over
there oh thank you again for
participating in our research the scan
will be performed in the pace
laboratories in Toronto but since we are
guests of our access is a bit
unpredictable I will try to schedule a
scan for Saturday I'll get back to you
when confirmed okay great happy to hear
your headaches have become less frequent
brain is slowly recovering what happened
to my brain why does my brain keep
bleeding since excessive stress could be
fatal I have written you a prescription
for prazosin to help you with your
nightmares please read the instruction
Medicaid accordingly Saturday off since
you probably forgot doctors but never
it's sent it's all connected for some
reason yeah okay so I got to find this
weird bizarre brain juice hello
okay cool give well soon what happened
to me this is before or after that oh
man there was something in here downtown
accident Cole it was after this
yesterday a driver distracted by her
child ran a red light causing her to
blindside a car holy crap oh man Simon
Jerrod that's my name
wait game game ends with a surprise is
that fortunate game ends with a surprise
I'm not so sure that's unintentional
there all right cinema Valley
japanimation bigger than ever
massive recoil flawless execution was
this oh and there's something there's a
lot to explore here this is upside down
though that doesn't exactly help me
trying to get to not that not that
not that either there's something going
on how am I supposed to be able to get
to that
you active tracer fluid okay fine I get
it okay I know I didn't need to do play
some video games and I put it in the
fridge put it here
I think the fast food uh-huh something
healthier my way home
absolutely not I'd never do that how
would I do that hello Simon Jarrett okay
that doesn't help me where's this fluid
where's the flood bathroom fluid oh it's
a nice day outside I'm looking for
radioactive teaser fluid however you say
that anybody in my shower know I'm so
excited because there's gonna be so many
custom sores I mean I'm not even through
the main game yet obviously but it's
going to be so many cool things there's
a lot of documentation about my brain
where the heck did I put the radioactive
fluid okay hello thank you
time to glug it down I guess oh all
right whatever
screw it yo lower such just yep slam it
good mmm but the taste it's like sucking
on a penny okay
little weird all right so what do I do
now how am I supposed to go out the door
now am i off on my way oh I'm off on my
way I don't know if there are any more
secrets than I could have found but I
was kind of thorough throughout the
apartment I mean a lot of this game in
especially amnesia will oh oh hi I am
pretty lady how are you doing like your
hair I like your suit very nice I ran
out of compliments I'll just look back
over here
okay I mean this is the first time that
I've seen NPCs it's really weird cuz
obviously oh hello yes answer Jessie
thanks I should be able to come to the
store after the skin don't sweat it
I got Matt guys help me out Madi from
SNL he's coming in full-time work in the
comic section that's Ashley's job yeah
forget it not doing her any favors by
leaving an empty spot not like she's
coming back dying thing you're the worst
support ever I'll see you later Jessie
don't burn the place down while I'm gone
okay what I was gonna say before is that
I'm obviously gonna compare a lot of
this damnation how the experience was
there but obviously there's NPCs here
which is a whole new experience for what
happened in the other game mods had to
be very creative about how they got NPCs
into the game usually was his flying
naked bed thrusting in my face not that
I minded but you know let's get a little
variety in your life hello my brain's
bleeding and apparently I'm dying dr.
munch you thought this place would be
busy huh I don't know always a bad sign
when it's not busy and things are
abandoned all right
hello I'm just gonna snoop a bit don't
mind me we've got a few hours I got
ahold of Simon Jared let's do this I saw
your laptop at reception area already
there talk to pace about using the lab
managed to book the scanner for Friday I
thought we could run some tests see
found some extra time in the lab
unfortunately no one told us the code
change okay so they're locked locked
down
alrighty then hello anybody no no one
okay was that somebody here
okay do I need to climb up there okay
maybe I should probably just try going
place right must be must be
hey bad David mangy let's just call much
real quick punchy boy monkey man okay so
phone turned off okay cool that's okay I
can figure this out can i I don't know
got it I don't know what is this so
there must be a code maybe I overlooked
it in that email let's see
locked out no code not allowed to repeat
the code mail or text but I'll leave a
note or something in case we forget okay
so there's a note here somewhere
with the code hello okay it's about
getting the brain to do the right thing
okay cool
there sure is a lot of stuff about the
brain over here can i plug this into the
computer okay I should probably stop
shoving random things into other things
hello
page 56 do 501 okay to 501 I think
that's it to 501 to 501 Boosh okay cool
okay cool thank you
ah you know okay there may be facility
where nothing could possibly go wrong oh
wait on that room I'll go in this room
first let me go in the first date good
it's not anything good for me in here
can't even open it great hope I don't
die hello I don't mind as I throw your
very valuable equipment all around the
room hope I'm not breaking anything
hello Oh a syringe can I tap this in me
ow okay there's got to be something else
that I need to do around here some of
the secret because I imagine there's
some semblance of choice in this because
if I didn't send off that email then it
would have been a very different call
from that other person so all things
considered there might be some variation
in what can be done in
game which would be really cool like I'm
not opposed to that in any way there
okay I guess that's it okay let's go
into the weird scary room that looks
like the evil within chamber where
they're gonna oh hey oh hi didn't hear
you come in Simon Jarrett right dr.
machi well it's just mr. Munchie but I'm
working on it
actually you're helping me right now is
this part of your thesis work yeah it's
a study I'm doing with my colleague Paul
Berg we hope to design a gentle way to
work with brain reconstruction to help
people like you oh did you take the
tracer fluid yes
yes I did great well we can start
whenever you're ready oh okay I only
have a few questions so you're not
really an actual doctor because I've had
encounters with people that aren't
actually really doctors operating on
people's brains and it doesn't usually
always turn out the way I kinda sorta
didn't want it let's just say doctorate
player lost his license a long time yeah
all right fine I'll have a seat
don't do anything too ridiculous my
brain don't mess with my giant enormous
collections of porn cuz I catalog that
throughout my entire life you better not
mess with it okay here we go
does sound of my brain crunching am I
gonna die maybe I'm already dead maybe
the game ends with a surprise all right
let me just get this out of the way I
feel Simon Jarrett
right Munchie born 1988 July 16 right
near a graph well this hurt is just a
scan it'll hurt about as much as getting
your picture taken Indians thought
cameras would steal their souls oh let's
hope they're wrong
ready no say cheese I regret everything
well hello that my soul just get removed
throughout my button oh that's good Oh
something tells me this doctor wasn't
too clear on what he was doing okay Oh
mr. Lucci Oh everything is horrible
something go wrong no something go wrong
this isn't funny
oh I'm having a grand old time laughs
all around okay I'm need to lay was this
aliens I don't have an omni tool I need
to get an omni tool where do I get an
omni tool my objective is very clear
this game as good as got that his blood
great cool
oh man I intentionally didn't look up
hardly anything about this game before I
actually got into it which was great
because it was apparently a really good
mystery they protected a lot about what
the story was honestly about before you
know the game actually came out but when
it did come out in it was of course it
would come out the one time when I
wasn't able to play it right away but
when it did come out I intentionally
avoided everything possible by doing
this okay omni tool chip installer fully
customized okey dokey so how do I get
inside okay so I need to find there's
got to be like a nominee tool around
here somewhere something that I can use
oh I forgot that I could throw things
excellent good I've already started my
rampage of destruction I'm sure no one
will mind in this abandoned place oh
gosh I'm sure that there aren't any
monsters that are gonna come after me I
was so exactly all this looks so much
like dead space oh hello haunted toilet
Oh lovely good I'll just be on my way
it's working better than expected
they're having a really hard time
getting the doors open for sale as many
as you can rather take any chances Jack
did you cut off the factory floor just
make sure to leave a way out of here I
have so many queer what is all of that
where is it using black pus I'm afeard
because some of the things that I did
see like seem to suggest that the
machines were coming alive in some way I
don't know the setting or the time or
why I'm here from my frickin brain scan
but the settings so cool oh so cool oh
I'm so excited oh I'm so excited
once again I don't know who did
oh sorry didn't mean oh okay anybody
want to pop out oh oh my vision
hello mr. robot man you seem to have a
face I don't like things with faces that
aren't well that is weird
that's sore is that is that like the
machines coming alive and injecting
their tentacles and all the other
machines to make weird creepy Robo sex
so what that black ooze was I don't want
to touch no Robo foods okay cool cool
cool don't don't come alive okay so what
stop that I touched you
hey you can you talk can you tell it
like the others
okay so that was okay I don't even think
about you can't scare me I know your
tricks I know what you're up to no I'm
gonna just run away as quick as I can
because I know your tricks what was that
was that black who's always here oh okay
glad I got that tutorial out of the way
okay so that door opened over there so
now I can go over this way and meet some
other horrible monstrosity and learn
more about why and how I'm here oh boy
Robo jizz all over the floor yeah well
you tryin to munch on that I'm sorry did
I miss something was there something
important that was gonna be shown to me
but I somehow missed it because I looked
away for once goddamn second probably
okay I still need to find it uh I still
need to find an omni tool hopefully I'm
gonna find one very soon hopefully hello
what are you that that's Chinese right
okay
this [ __ ] you am I being chased by
something or is there something actually
out there was that me was that me making
that mone noise I don't think that was
me
I heard a moaning someone's a moaning
out there I want to open that door I
mean I don't but I'm gonna open it I'm
gonna open you ha ha
see I knew you weren't gonna actually be
a thing there's something over here
first I want to look into cuz that boo
know maybe I'm gonna alright none of you
not a little bit of you Oh Oh God ah so
much Robo juice oh so much hey mommy -
good I got a high Matsu help her Jane
omni-tool hey that footsteps or is it
the slippy slappy Sasebo jizz I don't
think I want to know okay so I got a
helper Jane which is good I gasps I
don't have an inventory like the other
one okay what am i I don't know how to
let me just stand with this with my
mouth nice and open
hi you're a dead body you're a man that
was alive and now you're dead okay pull
kick okay I don't like was that me did I
do that
oh I did that oh okay all right I think
we're okay
generally speaking is anything in here
it definitely one of the things about
frictional games and especially the
reasonably amnesia the Dark Descent was
setting up a setting
yeah
okay all right I think we're okay I
don't know what it was but I didn't want
to hang around and look at it maybe it
was nothing could have been nothing
looked like something with tentacles and
usually my instinct when I see tentacles
I run as fast as I can okay
looking looking
okay we're okay it's just joking around
with noises I don't need to be too
scared of it I know what I know I know
I'll know when there's something to be
scared of because as I was saying
frictional games they're very good at
setting up the atmosphere and they're
very good at leading you into things and
getting you very much into everything
swype omni-tool tonight what a lot of
horse hockey yeah I guess I have to go
back and load up my omni-tool with
something else because in the beginning
when I first got here there was an
omni-tool lycra bear station now what I
don't seem to have is I don't seem to
have like a journal I don't seem to have
a notebook and oh that's uh hello would
you like to be my friend I have many
skills of friendship know what that
means
wait a minute was this open before I
don't recall seeing this last time I was
here
hello kurchuk thank you I wonder why
this was sealed off
oh that's right I went through the
window I went through the wall sweat
drop down my brain anybody who'll thanks
remote access denied emergency system 13
days remaining progress David Munchie
Toronto sub Simon Garrett Jarrett so
that does make sense but what is this
manish tool chip omni tools perfect
condition not fitted with a tool chip
okay insert a tool chip okay so I need
to unlock toolbox man's cortex
so many questions what the hell are you
talking about
you just said that I shouldn't be in
certain places and then I shouldn't be
hmm you said you said I shouldn't spread
viruses around and destroy the whole
place but apparently that doesn't matter
to you cuz you're just such a badass all
right let me shove this in here all
right cool that was sexy
great why all right I'm the tool man
still chip update oh boy
I'm doing a thing this game makes me
feel like I'm actually smart that didn't
sound good okay so I don't have the
other thing which was like a new daddy
what's this hello somebody analyze this
analyze and in the comments below tell
me who Kate I saw words restoring
something does power I saw that I saw
the word David let me just see if it
loops is this yeah that's the same thing
okay
well that was unreported Simkin replaced
heat-sealed sempkin reported
uncharacteristic levels of nausea after
the mission what mission pilot system
increasingly unreliable what I don't
know what does any of that mean where am
I
how did I get here okay so I've got a
chip a level 3 chip not that I know what
that means and there was a light coming
through hello that looks like eyeballs
I'm gonna go towards that oh okay okay
I'm gonna go this way now okay all right
cool
all right I know in the base section
lights up that I'll get everyone I need
to go that way okay I always wanted to
go this way this way is my favorite way
oh oh this is this shortcut okay okay ah
here we go
Oh underwater
oh is that preview that I saw a while
ago I'm underwater cool why I don't know
okay cool you're gonna miss this place
oh boy oh that's a shark to puss that's
not good that sharks done been infected
by alien machines oh they don't look so
good I didn't see none of this stuff
outside I was it looking at pretty
little fishes oh they look normal
oh okay I don't know what that means I'm
just gonna assume that one was good I'm
in the ocean aren't I
I have very strict feelings about the
ocean I have very strong opinions about
the ocean everybody get ready to form a
human raft and swim out into the middle
of the ocean and save my ass
looky security okay oh I missed it mmm
that pungent smell
okay Oh
how's it going oh you're pulsating oh no
no no no no why did you touch it
yeah freakin idiot why would you touch a
pulsating Robo vagina why why would you
do that it's not kosher it's not good
why would you do that geez wrong with
you Oh shouldn't I have gotten like a
security suit to try to put oh okay
nevermind we're gonna load a little bit
I probably should have gotten scared to
see the some sort to try to protect
myself from the environment and invading
Robo tentacles those aren't good sounds
[ __ ] you yeah you know You Know Who I am
huh just give me a chair give me a chair
I dare you
yeah that's locked oh it's weird cuz it
feels like I'm in a space station but
I'm actually just underwater I guess
they're similar they don't want anything
on the outside getting in or anything
inside getting out so lots of mechanical
systems to keep us organic flesh bags
alive
well that's locked too good gravy is
there anything I can do to unlock these
I doubt it
nope okay so I went every wrong
direction I could and now I will get the
right answer cuz I'm a smarty poo I I
guess I should have read the sign I got
a bad feeling about this
I meant to say that earlier by the way I
got a bad feeling about all the bleeding
in my brain oh good yeah well I see you
over there
squiggling with your tentacles why all
the Robo [ __ ] everywhere Oh what is
that what is that what is that what is
that what are you what is that what is
that is it what is it what is it don't
touch the structure gel leakage can't
confirm its effect on Wow issue has been
reported don't touch what is that what
do you do oh god just oh what are you
doing what are what are you doing what
are you doing to that Robo vagina
hello hi I'm gonna talk to you cuz
that's normal hey can you hear me
okay all right this little bizarre all
right okay okay all right
I guess that's enough for the first
episode I'll find out what's on the
other side of the door after I'm done
watching this guy do something crazy
with that Robo booboo Jana
anyway thank you everybody so much for
watching I can't wait to play more than
I'm actually gonna immediately play more
of this afterwards but expect daily
uploads a thirty minute videos in this
game all the way until it's done so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video